hier soir vous savez canal plus diffusé
je ne suis pas une [ __ ] je suis
journaliste un documentaire de marie
portolano consacrée aux femmes
journalistes de sport victimes de
sexisme au sein de leur milieu
elles étaient nombreuses à venir
témoigne estelle denis nathalie iannetta
et isabelle ithurburu elles ont pris la
parole pour dénoncer du sexisme
ordinaire voire des agressions sexuelles
qu'elles ont vécu dans l'exercice de
leur métier
un documentaire choc voilà qu'elle fait
énormément d'encre et une personnalité
était particulièrement pointé du doigt
c'est pierre ménès puisque le média les
jo a révélé qu'une interview de pierre
ménès n'avait pas été sélectionné dans
le documentaire moi vous expliquer
pourquoi dans un instant et dans cette
interview on apprenait que pierre ménès
voilà aurait porté atteinte à la
journaliste marie portolano il évoque
notamment un soir où aux pierres
auraient eu un comportement limite avec
marie portolano alors on va vous
diffuser dans un instant cette séquence
dans l'intégralité ça dure 3 minutes 30
environ cette séquence qui a été coupée
ou pire menace réagira avec nous et
c'est vrai que si vous n'étiez pas au
courant c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'était partout sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis hier on ne parle que de ça et
dans un instant il aura francesca
antoniotti que vous connaissez notre ami
un bien sûr qu'ils travaillaient avec
pierre ménès est avec nous sur touche
pas à mon sport c'était le 13 mai 2016
et il ya une vidéo qui est ressorti on
va en parler avec francesca pour savoir
ce qu'elle en pense
et bien entendu pierre arrivé dans un
instant petit récap de toute cette
histoire
[Musique]
hier soir canal + diffusé un
documentaire événement qui depuis ce
matin fait beaucoup parler je ne suis
pas une [ __ ] je suis une journaliste
voilà le titre choc de ce programme
porté par marie portolano je vais vous
raconter l'une des faces cachées de mon
métier un documentaire dans lequel des
femmes journalistes sportifs témoigne
pour raconter le monde misogyne dans
lequel elle évolue
estelle denis isabelle moreau vanessa
lemoine isabelle ithurburu charlotte
namura voici quelques noms de celles qui
témoignent de ces humiliations ou
atteintes sexuelles en dur et où nous a
enfermés avec mon collègue n'entendons
cache la clé dans sa poche
disons faubert la chercheure soutien
mais si la parole s'est libérée hier sur
canal+ certains accusent la chaîne
d'avoir voulu protéger son journaliste
pierre ménès en effet un passage
revenant sur plusieurs événements entre
le commentateur et des journalistes en
plateau aurait été enlevé par choix
éditorial en voulant donner
spécifiquement la parole aux femmes
un documentaire qui n'est pas la réalité
d'un univers qui peut se révéler parfois
très misogyne à la télévision depuis
plusieurs séquences éxiste impliquant
pierre ménès ont été publiées sur les
réseaux dont une avec francesca
antonetti elle est avec nous ce soir
pour nous donner son ressenti
[Musique]
merci francesca d'être là merci à vous
de m'avoir invité
merci je suis très content de te voir en
plus ce que ça fait longtemps qu'on sait
pas vu et j'ai plein de projets à te
présenter parce que tu es formidable
machine vous voulez revenir avec toi je
te tutoie pas se mentir sur une séquence
qui de qui ce resort sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis hier c'était le 13 mai
2016 sur le plateau de touche pas à mon
sport à l'époque à la suite d'un pari
visiblement fait dans les loges que
c'est vrai que c'est à des causes
apparemment beaucoup dans les loges et
de paris il ya pas de paris nous
apprennent pas boxer c'est ça c'est pas
vrai donc oui
non mais il l'a expliqué comme ça mais
il n'y avait pas il n'ya pas pire menace
nous embrassons direct sur le plateau
est votre réaction à beaucoup fait
réagir les internautes
on va revoir cette séquence on va savoir
ce que vous en pensez sait pas alors à
paris avec son ventre et je leur banc
des remplaçants il remplace
[Applaudissements]
des mois il apparaît en loge avec un
sari ou l'inde j'ai fait un pari que si
elle disait c'est important d'avoir
double entrée que je l'embrassais donc
voilà alors 30 jusqu'à c'est vrai que
cette vidéo elle est ressortie tout le
monde on reparle aujourd'hui vous est-ce
que tu comprends que cette vidéo se
passe polémique aujourd'hui déjà ça me
dérange un petit peu de revenir ici pour
ça parce que j'aurais aimé venir dans
d'autres conditions mais l'arbre les
positions du g tu veux mais la polémique
a pris tellement d'ampleur et j'ai reçu
des messages de beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes beaucoup de femmes des députés
aussi voilà des gens très important ça
va un petit peu dépassé donc je me suis
dit vas-y parce que faut pas que tu
caches ces faut que tu exprimes toi ton
ressenti donc j'ai voulu venir pour être
très honnête alors déjà première chose
je vais vraiment être transparents sur
le moment je les ai pas du tout vécu
comme une agression sexuelle parce que
c'est le terme que j'entends et qui est
employé sur les réseaux sociaux
alors c'est la définition c'est la
définition d'une agression sexuelle moi
je n'ai pas du tout vécu comme ça mais
elle est vécue comme une humiliation
parce qu'après il faut être honnête il
faut aussi dire les choses parfois dans
ce métier là en tant que journaliste
sportive on se retrouve à être humilié
parce que yahia voilà il ya des mots qui
sont blessants il ya des comportements
et le fait qu'on soit une femme
voilà autorise certains a manqué de
respect et ce geste cela quand je le
revois voilà c'est pas agréable c'est
pas agréable
maintenant de le dire de dire que je les
ai vécus comme une agression sexuelle ce
serait faux c'était une humiliation
c'est c'est eh quoi on va passer la
dernière partie de l'émission mais juste
c'était quoi ta relation avec pierre
vous étiez très peu ou pas on a toujours
été ce planning et j'ai un profond
respect pour lui c'est un journaliste
que j'admire c'est vrai que dans ce
milieu là il ya des gens qui sont des
décideurs il ya des gens qui comptent et
il ya des gens bas on n'ose pas leur
dire sur le moment j'aurais dû lui dire
mais qu'est ce que tu fais tu es fou
j'aurais dû pouvoir et plus devoir
parler après ou pas du tout esclave de
jo privat on n'a même pas parlé j'ai eu
un message des stèles tout à l'heure qui
m'a dit c'est fou je suis choquée en
regardant les images et je comprends pas
pourquoi je t'en ai pas reparlé et vient
d'être fait à l'époque j'avais vu deux
chars rigole grave mais wifi rigole sur
le papier évidemment commencer ce que
vous avez vu en fait c'est en voyant les
images toi comme tu l'as là en voyant
des images je suis très dérangé ça me
dérange c'est des images qui voit là
samedi ça m'amuse pas il s'est pacsé son
ami jean tu t'es dit voilà c'est pas sur
le coup en fait il ya plein de choses
qu'on laisse passer parce que 1 déjà on
a envie de bosser qu'on n'a pas envie de
se disputer avec avec des gens qui sont
plutôt des gens qu'on respecte dans ce
milieu là et mine de rien quand on est
dans le journaliste sportif on n'a pas
non plus la possibilité de trop trop
dire ce qu'on pense qu'on pense qu'on
ressent quand on est gêné par un
comportement
voilà c'est vrai que pierre il en impose
j'ai peut-être pas osé lui dire vraiment
ce que je ressentais sur le moment voilà
encore une fois c'était une agression
ait parlé avec pays ou pas non jamais
jamais non ouais et et toi ton nokia
jamais pour penser juste là maintenant
quand a revu les images c'est très
honnête ça m'empêche pas de dormir
voilà d'accord oui puisque toulouse le
fait que tout le monde tape et elle que
tout le monde tant pain est ce que ça
t'a fait réfléchir mais est-ce que tu
dernier oui parce qu'à une chose qui est
importante c'est ce que moi j'ai accepté
en essuyant un peu un peu les poutres en
arrivant très jeune journaliste j'étais
un peu une des premières femmes et je me
suis pris je me suis pris vraiment plein
la tronche il est il est témoin un gilet
leur dette ça a été vraiment très très
dur je parle pas du tout de pierre
forcément je parle de deux pleins
d'hommes qui ont été vraiment dur avec
moi et voilà je me suis battu j'ai fait
ma place et à un moment donné je me suis
dit éloigne toi parce que tu vas te
faire mal que ce soit sur les réseaux
sociaux
que ce soit en interne avec les gens
avec qui je bossais j'ai vraiment
souffert
donc je me suis dit éloigne-toi du
journalisme sportif et je pense que les
filles qui arrivent maintenant ils n'ont
pas à subir ce que moi je suis bi et
peut-être qu'elles sont plus sensibles
peut-être que ce qu'on accepte à mon
époque on doit plus accepter
donc moi je me devais de venir ici et de
dire voilà j'ai été humilié
je sais que pierre il est intelligent il
va s'excuser il va dire qu'il va pas
refaire ce genre de choses et puis voilà
basta quoi